Speaker 1: All right, let's get into some
interesting news items from the weekend, the
most interesting and the biggest one and the
one that has the most is sort of comical implications
is that they finished the audit in Arizona.
Now, I'm not even sure whether I should be
using the term audit because it wasn't really
an audit, but what was being described as
an audit in Arizona meant to uncover, depending
on your beliefs, that Joe Biden didn't really
win and that Donald Trump really did has finished.
And it found not only did Joe Biden win, he
actually won by a larger margin.
His margin of victory actually expanded.
So let's look at some of the reporting on
this.
You might think, well, this is the end, right?
This is no, they now want more audits.
They want another audit in Arizona.
They want another audit elsewhere.
And we'll look at a whole area.
Second article which points out the point
of these audits, audits is not exactly clear.
So Associated Press Republican Review finds
no proof Arizona election stolen from Trump.
That we could stop there, but the details
are actually even funnier, a Republican backed
review of the 20 20 presidential election
in Arizona's largest county ended Friday without
producing proof to support former President
Donald Trump's false claims of a stolen election.
This is maybe my favorite news paragraph of
the last six months.
After six months of searching for evidence
of fraud, the firm hired by Republican lawmakers
issued a report that experts described as
riddled with errors, bias and flawed methodology.
Still, even that partizan review came up with
a vote tally that would not have altered the
outcome, finding that Biden won by 360 more
votes than the official results certified
last year.
OK, it was biased.
It was partizan.
It may not even have been an audit, but they
came up with a final number, and it's Joe
Biden actually won by 360 more than what the
results were in November.
Now, when you look at the actual margin and
then you compare it to three hundred and sixty
votes, it's irrelevant.
OK, the article goes on to say, the finding
was an embarrassing end to a widely criticized
and at times bizarre quest to prove allegations
that election officials and courts have rejected.
It has no bearing on the final certified results.
Previous reviews of the two point one million
ballots by nonpartisan officials, professionals
that followed state law have found no significant
problem with the vote count in Maricopa County,
home to Phenix.
Biden won the county by 45000 votes, key to
his ten thousand five hundred vote win of
Arizona.
This was why they focused on Maricopa, because
if Maricopa is big enough population wise
that if it was really wrong, it could have
flipped the election results.
Of course, there was never a reason to think
that the results were really wrong for many
critics.
The conclusions presented at the hearing Friday
by the firm Cyber Ninja's.
It's crazy that this is the world we live
in.
OK, cyber ninjas underscored the futility
of the exercise, which has helped fuel skepticism
about the validity of the 2020 election and
spawned copycat audits nationwide.
Now, you might think it's over now.
It's not there is another article from the
Associated Press from the day after these
results from Saturday Explainer As Arizona
election audit ends, new ones begin.
The most closely watched attempt by Republicans
to examine the 2020 presidential election
in a battleground state lost by former President
Donald Trump is coming to an embarrassing
end in Arizona, but their efforts are cranking
up elsewhere.
The most recent is in Texas.
We'll talk about this on the bonus show where
the secretary of state's office announced
Thursday it would conduct a full and comprehensive
audit, forensic audit of the 2020 election
in four counties.
These this is this is my favorite.
These reviews go by various names, audits
or investigations, sometimes with the word
forensic attached.
But their scope is not always well defined
or understood, even by those pushing them,
which is true.
Sometimes you'll talk to the people involved
and they'll say, we don't really know what
the mechanism is, where what we would uncover
would really change anything, but we're doing
it.
Critics say they really have one goal to validate
Trump's baseless claims that widespread fraud
cost him the election, regardless of what
the reviews might find.
So this is the humiliating end of the much
publicized Arizona audit.
Now, we already talked earlier about at his
rally on Saturday, if you were waiting for
Trump to say, hey, guys, you know what?
I asked for an audit.
They did the audit.
Turns out Joe Biden really won.
If you were waiting for that, if you were
holding your breath for that, you're probably
running out of breath right now.
Of course, he didn't do that.
He said actually, the the audit results show
I really, really won just a total and total,
total, complete liar.
Will Sommer, who has been a guest on our show,
has been covering this and actually tweeted,
Arizona audit backers have been distancing
themselves for weeks saying you can't really
find fraud in a recount or as in the case
of Michael Flynn, posting this bizarre letter
from the people demanding the Arizona Senate
consider reports from even bigger kooks than
cyber ninjas.
Yeah, it was never going to find anything.
There was nothing to find based on the evidence
we had, but it was never going to find anything
unless they just straight up lied.
So what's next?
It's over, right?
No.
Now they're moving on to Texas.
We'll talk about that on the bonus show